okay this is a little bit different so
um i told you i've been kind of delving
into trauma and how to recover from
trauma
so
how do you recover from shared traumatic
experiences so that you're not setting
each other off by reminding them of the
trauma you guys both have gone through
what a great question and that's a bit
of a tricky one i think over this past
year and a half a lot of people have
been through yeah yeah experiences
quarantining together
well yeah but you know like i mean i
live in new york city the you know it
was it was the epicenter at the
beginning a lot of people here
have this look and they tell you oh the
sirens because that first
month people were just locked in their
apartments afraid to go outside and all
you had were sirens day and night every
several times an hour you just couldn't
get away from it and so
the sirens were so traumatic it felt
like the end of the world and um yeah
but how you get over trauma
number one is that two things i want to
say about that that a little
counterintuitive for people most people
think that the psychologist would say
oh if it's trauma you have to talk about
it you gotta bring it out you gotta like
you know get it out of your system you
have to debrief about it that's not
necessarily true there are people when
they've been through traumatic events
that feel the need
to talk about them
and if you feel the need to talk about
the traumatic events you should but
there are people who go through the same
traumatic event and actually feel the
need to not
talk about it they feel that they'd
rather compen compartmentalize it and
just kind of move on i don't want to
talk about it i just want to move on and
for those people who don't want to talk
about it who are able to
compartmentalize and move on being
forced to talk about it
um can actually be more scarring
than not after 9 11 in new york city
there was one study that showed that the
more people spoke
about the events the harder it was for
them
to move past them that the people who
experienced similar events but didn't
talk about them because they didn't want
to um did better long term so it's an
individual thing you need to know
whether you feel the need to talk and
some people definitely feel the need to
i don't agree with it i just want to
move on
and and if you're the move on type then
it's not great for you to talk and if
you're the talker type it's important
and so
that is also important when it's to
people because you hope to be matched
there i mean
often it's one person like i really want
to talk and the other person i really
don't
because i don't want to get
re-traumatized every time you have a
memory you're kind of
really you're laying down that memory
again and so you're bringing it up in a
traumatic way you're actually making
that trauma
worse and so for the person who doesn't
want to do it it's not wise for them to
then maybe the other person should find
you know someone to talk to who does
want to talk about things but even to
have that conversation what's your
preference to something you want to talk
about etc
the other thing about trauma just the
most you know known thing about trauma
is that the best way through it
is to um find meaning and you can only
do that in a certain distance of time
and and and emotional distance but to
find meaning to have a way to extract
something from that event that it taught
you that it showed you that you could
make changes based on and then it has
purpose or utility even if it was very
very difficult and that often takes that
edge
off
you know what the trauma does
or the scars that it leaves
yeah
purposeless suffering is much much worse
than
suffering and learning something or
being able to help somebody because you
experienced something or yeah
something like that does
so you talked about how some people are
better
or they prefer to compartmentalize
versus talk about it does that have a
lot to do with how soon after the
traumatic experience occurred they're
trying to delve into it like if they
wait a certain amount of time
then do some people
go from compartmentalizing it's hard to
say to talking about it
yeah i mean there can be an initial
shock period literally um these uh you
know the the in when there's certain you
know um
mass events then then you have most
people who experience uh trauma or shock
are actually taken to hospitals for
evaluation the the non-physically
damaged are also taken to hospitals and
they're considered among the injured
because they are injured now that
initial shock
um
subsides you know after however many
hours or days and then what are you left
with and so it may be in those in that
first few moments where you're still
coming to terms with what what happened
here
um it's hard to tell are you somebody
who needs to talk or or not but in the
days after again you will feel that need
uh once that shock is passed a bit to to
want to talk about it or you'll feel the
need to i don't and you'll know that
very clearly and it's very it's similar
with grief when people lose a relative
sometimes the assumption is because we
have all these rituals about the
community coming together to talk about
things but sometimes some people like
can we just not talk about them though
because i i i'm
up for the distraction but i just don't
want to talk that's too painful for me
to talk about that
so even in grief sometimes people can
can have that choice but you know it
because you you feel like oh i don't
want to do this or i really want to do
this i wish somebody could listen
you know that about yourself
yeah
it's complicated
i've had a number of experiences i
wouldn't recommend i mean everybody has
and i've noticed
depending on the experience i'll either
go into i don't want to talk about it
like don't try and get into my head and
dissect whatever i'm thinking don't want
to talk about it
to oh i need to write about it or you
know talking to a therapist would help
depending on how tough the situation is
maybe sometimes it takes a certain
period of time then i'm like okay now i
can talk about it but it's been a year
and you said something very important
there and that's the
the writing part because
writing is super super super useful
because it helps you it's private so you
don't have to share it with someone but
it helps you organize your thoughts
because when we have
those big feelings attached to whatever
the traumatic event were was
then it's sometimes hard to you know
like when you're feeling that it's hard
to organize your thoughts because you're
feeling something so strongly it kind of
shuts down the minute we go back to our
to our more primitive uh
in terms of evolution uh more primitive
structures it takes away from our
executive functioning from the newer
ones and so i've you know the more upset
we are the the less
thinking we can do with clarity
writing forces emotional distance
because to translate what the thought
and feeling is into words that you then
organize and actually do the fine motor
skill of writing them down or typing
them
it it is a laborious uh mental execution
that actually creates emotional distance
and then lowers the emotional response
enough for you to have more clarity in
your thinking about it so it's very
useful as a way to especially when
you're feeling
a lot of things to to or you're feeling
things very strongly to organize your
thoughts to get your own bearings before
you then
you know like a lot of people say like i
can't talk to somebody to know what i
think first or what i feel first well
writing is a great way to get in touch
with it
okay i love that i found writing really
useful um when i was
actually i still do this sometimes if i
get really really wound up in an
argument or there's too many things
going on in my brain
and i'm in an argument with somebody
sometimes i find arguing over
by writing is actually
a good way to ease into that when i was
like going back to my first relationship
in high school
before texting was really a thing
i would
and maybe this was weird but if i got
really mad about something i'd write it
down so i'd be able to tell them that
way but i didn't have the
i was too stressed out or worried just
like i can't talk about this but like
this is why i'm angry
i found that really useful even though
it kind of felt like cheating
i don't think it's cheating at all
look for for someone like me um the the
ideal there is
what makes the communication best
right i mean that's the goal like what
allows you to communicate
best and for you if you were to talk
about it and you would get upset and
then it would be harder to articulate
what's going on with you
versus writing it down again with that
emotional distance it forces and the
ability to articulate things because you
can go and you can edit and you can
truly and some people actually the you
know our verbal expression and our
written expression is not
in line with a lot of people some people
are much stronger in one than the other
they can speak amazingly write poorly or
vice versa so you writing was you
communicating as clearly as you could so
to me that's the win
right i mean that's the smart thing to
do and i sometimes recommend to couples
who've been together for a long time if
they're explosive if they tend to kind
of go from zero to war of the roses in
like two sentences do it via text do it
via you know emails because
the other person won't interrupt you
they won't you know like speak over you
they won't start yelling when you're in
the middle of what you want to say you
actually get to finish what you say they
get to finish what they say so if you're
having trouble communicating because
it's too explosive do it in text do it
in writing that to me that's that's not
a cheat and it's actually the more
efficient
way to do it sometimes
you